the second thing is what the story the
creation stories in Genesis for example
actually mean because they actually mean
something and what they mean is that
absolutely remarkable in my estimation
and so I'm going to tell you a little
bit about that story because it's
necessary to understand what the story
means to determine if what Nietzsche
said about the inevitable destruction of
our symbolic religious structures by
science was inevitable and necessary and
I think the answer to that is no we just
didn't understand what the hell we were
doing any more than we really understand
why we put up Christmas trees at
Christmas so we do that in part because
the Christmas tree is a symbol of life
because the tree is a symbol of life
because we inhabited trees for untold
millions of years and we put lights on
the trees to symbolize the coming back
into the darkness of midwinter of the
Sun and the light and so we play this
symbolic game that celebrates both life
and the emergence of light and
consciousness and we associate that with
the birth of the Savior but we don't
know that we're doing that but we do it
anyways and and we do that sort of thing
all the time because we're smarter than
we know and that has to be the case
because we don't know ourselves we would
need a psychology or sociology and
anthropology or any of those things if
we were transparent to ourselves we're
machines so to speak that are far more
intelligent and wise than the machines
themselves can understand and we've
revealed ourselves to ourselves in our
action and our symbolic gestures
constantly and then have to reflect on
that to try to understand what it is
that we're up to